nos encontramos en el tramo final de
este tortuoso camino hacia encontrar la
inversa de una matriz de 3 por 3 que ya
encontramos sacamos la matriz de menores
utilicemos este tablero de ajedrez con
más y menos para encontrar la matriz de
cofactores que simplemente multiplicar
estos signos con un 1 aquí al lado por
esta matriz de menores y pues para sacar
la inversa de esta matriz ya lo único
que nos falta es sacar el determinante
de esta matriz y tomar uno entre el
determinante y multiplicarlo por la
matriz transpuesta de esta matriz de
cofactores ok entonces una forma de
sacar el determinante de esta matriz ya
que aquí calculamos todos estos menores
es escoger una fila lo más fácil es
multiplicar por esta fila tomamos esta
entrada y multiplicamos por la menor de
esta entrada
por el símbolo en este tablero de
ajedrez
y a eso sumarle la multiplicación de
esta entrada por la menor de esta
entrada por el símbolo de esta entrada
y al final sumarle esta última entrada
por la menor de esa entrada y por el
símbolo de esa entrada
ok como aquí ya calculamos las entradas
resulta hacer algo muy sencillo pero
también podemos obtener el determinante
de esta matriz utilizando el otro método
que vimos para encontrar determinantes y
para que veas que sale exactamente el
mismo determinante vamos a usar este
método
aunque entonces pues necesitamos más
espacio así es que vamos a copiar esta
matriz y se acuerdan en cuál era el
método para sacar el determinante de
esta matriz lo que hacíamos era poner
aquí la matriz y luego tomar estas
primeras dos filas y colocarlas aquí y
tomar estas diagonales a esta diagonal y
esta diagonal multiplicar cada una de
las entradas de cada diagonal y sumar el
resultado de las multiplicaciones y
después tomar las otras diagonales osea
en lo que obtendríamos en esta diagonal
con esta diagonal y esta diagonal y
restar el resultado de la multiplicación
de cada una de las diagonales ok vamos a
usar este método para repasar este
método aquí tenemos que poner menos 123
menos 2 1
42 15 eso es tal cual nuestra matriz y
ahora vamos a agregarle estas dos filas
o sea tenemos que agregar un menos 123
- 214 y vamos a sacar la multiplicación
de esta primera diagonal o sea menos uno
por uno por cinco eso cuánto es eso es
menos cinco no menos cinco y queremos
sumarle lo que nos queda de la
multiplicación de esta segunda columna
que es menos dos por uno por tres menos
dos por tres es menos seis y por uno
pues otra vez menos seis entonces de
esta diagonal la multiplicación nos
queda menos seis ya esto tenemos que
sumarle lo que nos quede en multiplicar
la tercera diagonal que es dos por dos
por cuatro
o sea que tenemos cuatro por dos por dos
o sea que tenemos 4 12
2 a la 4 es 16 16 de esta diagonal y
ahora tenemos que restarle lo que nos
quede de tomar estas diagonales
multiplicar lo que haya dentro de la
diagonal y restárselo a esto entonces
menos 2 x 2 - cuatro menos cuatro por
cinco eso es menos 20 pero tenemos que
restarle ok menos menos 20 y aquí en
esta otra diagonal nos queda menos uno
por uno menos uno por cuatro menos
cuatro ok menos cuatro y finalmente en
esta última diagonal
lo que tenemos es 2 por 1 2 por 3 6 o
sea aquí tenemos que restarle por eso
está dentro de este paréntesis
entonces ya vamos a hacer esta suma y
nos queda menos cinco más menos seis eso
es menos 11 - 11 más 16
eso lo que nos queda es un 5 entonces de
todas estas diagonales que estábamos un
mandado nos queda un 5 y de estas
diagonales que le tenemos que restar nos
queda menos 20 menos 4 en sus menos 24
más 6 eso es menos 18 no entonces de
esto es menos 10 y 8 pero pues estamos
restando lo no entonces nos queda
5 - menos 18 o sea aquí tenemos más
y 518 eso es 23 que entonces el
determinante de c en el determinante de
nuestra matriz c es igual a 23 bueno
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer ese
espacio para escribir la inversa de la
matriz entonces vamos a mover estas
cosas a la izquierda y ahora sí ahora sí
ya tenemos la matriz c inversa aquí
porque ya tenemos el determinante y ya
tenemos la matriz de cofactores y
entonces ya lo único que falta es tomar
la transpuesta de esta matriz de
cofactores y multiplicarla por 1 entre
23 ok a qué me refiero con eso que
tomemos la matriz transpuesta de una
matriz pues simplemente tomamos por
ejemplo osea si ésta es la primera fila
en la matriz transpuesta lo que vamos a
tener es que esta es la primera columna
aunque entonces a ver es igual
la primera columna de la matriz
transpuesta de la matriz de cofactores
es 1 - 7
5 la segunda columna de la matriz
transpuesta es la segunda fila de
nuestra matriz de cofactores o sea aquí
tenemos un 18 11 menos 2 y finalmente la
tercera fila de nuestra matriz de
cofactores va a ser nuestra tercera
columna aunque hay aquí va un -4 5 y 3
gay
esta es la matriz de cofactores
transpuesta y para que sea igual a la
inversa de ser tenemos que multiplicar
por 1 entre 23 aunque sería mejor
meterlo dentro de la matriz y entonces
lo que nos queda es 1 entre 23
y aquí nos queda 18 20 y 13 años y menos
423 sea vos y menos 723
ahora sí ahora sí esta matriz si es la
inversa de nuestra matriz c y ya muy
bien acá vamos a invertir una matriz de
tres por tres si es que no nos
equivocamos en alguna cuenta en el
camino que es lo más común y bueno es
por todos esos errores que uno comete a
la hora de sumar y restar números que yo
pienso que este tipo de cálculos si es
muy importante que lo sepamos hacer así
perfectamente qué es lo que está pasando
en cada uno de los pasos pero que pues
ya que ya que sabemos cómo se hacen pues
uno tiene que hacerlos en la computadora
para nuestras equivocan no en fin te veo
en el próximo vídeo